What's hot in here?
Uh,
Lights out is solved.
Whisker eraser works
zero some
health.
Okay.
Um, I was a little hungry today, so I
got myself um some lean
lean steak.
I forgot how hungry I get when I do like
a full workday.
Racer is done.
Earth is messed up.
Okay,
sweep running on new env
self ships with cannons and selfplay.
How hard is it to write a scripted bot
convert?
Because usually for new ends, it's good
to have a a scripted bot before you do
full selfplay.
Not useful though if it's like checkers
or makes the ends 20k SPS.
Hello there.
Welcome.
saw a video when you were at Lucid. Sh.
That was uh peak blunder years for me.
It's pretty funny though.
literally run around doing iikido rolls.
I would do that at parties, too. It was
super dumb.
But hey, got to have fun once in a
while.
Exactly. Not something for this weekend,
Kvert.
Okay, so asteroids was just the end was
bugged. Nice.
You ever worked on an audio dubbing
pipeline? No.
Lime volley is very weird. That doesn't
just work.
solve. Okay.
Can we have full slime volley?
I thought we had full slime volley
solve.
Yeah, we have full slime volley solve in
how long?
Uh, less than a minute.
It's a pure regression and we can it can
figure that out just from a regression
Yeah. I'm going to do another couple
hours, I think, tonight. Just until I
start getting tired.
Crap. Deck classic.
I think that one works, doesn't it?
Uh oh. Okay, that's sketchy.
is my primary
concern.
I'm describing fairly straightforward
stuff to it.
I mean,
and there's a little bit of subtlety in
some of the stuff. Not much. It's all
under the like what I would consider
pretty routine work, though.
balancing fundamentals.
Do you know C? If not, go learn to write
some C by hand.
Actually, puffer Ms are a great way to
do that.
Lots of people uh got started with
puffer just like writing some ends by
hand in C.
If you haven't done that type of stuff
before, you will be surprised to see how
fast code can be like really brain dead
simple code. Like, oh, this N runs 10
million steps per second on one thread.
Huh.
We explicitly don't do LLM. We do
everything else.
I don't find it particularly
interesting. Um, I don't think there's
too much you can really do in the space
just because of how big and stupid
everything is. And I figure like there's
enough people doing that stuff anyways.
The stuff I'm doing here will not get
done if I don't do it. Nobody else will
do it.
What's this project about? Ultra high
performance reinforcement learning.
You can play with our stuff on
puffer.ai.
Got lots of demos.
They run in your browser.
hardware structure.
I mean, honestly,
like the basics, I kind of didn't have
to. If you're used to writing C, it's
like, okay, so it's C that runs on your
GPU. So, the GPU has a bunch of cores
and they're all sim,
huh? Okay.
Well, I can do that. Sure. And you just
sort of start writing some stuff. And
then you learn, okay, it's a little more
complicated with synchronization and
launch overhead and graphs and this and
that, but really not that bad.
optimizing stuff that has matt moles in
the pipeline and like all sorts of stuff
there. Okay, it gets very difficult.
But your basic kernels are just like LM
wise parallel ops
in C. Pretty simple.
Whatever. We'll not bother. We'll We'll
be fine with this for now.
Still in.
Okay. Other ends.
How can I train a model to beat it in a
soccer game? Kinvert literally has a PR
open for like a soccer and with Puffer.
I'm going to merge that this We can't
Why? New to your channel. What are you
doing exactly?
Right now, I'm basically just triaging a
bunch of random minor binding upgrades
and fixes to all of our different RLNs.
So, we have all these different RL
environments and they're all getting
upgraded for Puffer 50.
And they're just miscellaneous porting
errors that I'm sort of just
orchestrating tiny little fixes to in
tests.
Um, I usually do this manually every
release, but we have too many bloody
environments, so this would take me two
weeks. I figure I just do it this way.
It's easy, and we'll just make sure that
nothing gets screwed up in the process.
Um, I'm using uh Grock because it's
faster,
pretty simple.
If I become a tribute, I get eligible
that GPT was giving. Um, so I didn't
take them up on any of those offers
because they they basically come with
the right to use your project logo and
stuff on their website, which no thank
you.
I know. I just have a bit I just have
like the whatever Grock heavy plan.
I've tried all of them. It really
doesn't there's not a big difference in
capability among any of them. The only
thing that I really do notice is when
they're slow as hell.
Like they all make the same dumb stupid
errors constantly.
Um they're not good at writing decent
code, but they're still useful.
What in the hell? Oh, this is [ __ ]
Elliot's goddamn like crazy AVX [ __ ]
Damn it, Elliot. All right, we'll fix
that. It's all right. Craftex is a
bigger project. I just want something
that smoke test for now and we'll fix it
later.
I'd honestly be most happy if I could
just jam some like C and write myself a
little sim right now. That'd be way more
fun than any of this.
Turn all the models off. Just jam some
C.
reward functions.
All right, here's how you design a
reward function. Step one, you try the
sparse reward. All right, step two, if
that doesn't work and there's not like
an obvious score or whatever, you pick
five things that you think are relevant
and then you use protein to hyper param
sweep the uh the waitings of them.
That's literally it.
Reward design is like shitty and
annoying.
and you generally shouldn't be doing it.
Way more important that you get like
observation, curriculum,
um any sort of domain randomization.
Those sorts of things matter a lot more.
What the
Oh, okay. Fine. Yeah. Yeah. I don't
care. This is This is all going to go
anyways. This is crazy ass terrain gen
[ __ ]
working on Grock
again. It's faster.
That's literally it. It's just faster.
If solve reward equals 1. If solver
reward equals 1. Actually, that will
work a good chunk of the time. Like, if
you can run your N for uh 2 million
steps and you'll randomly get the reward
once typically, like that's enough for
Puffer to solve it,
assuming that your Env is fast. If your
Env is fast, make if your Env is slow,
make your end fast before doing anything
else.
He does a lot of like, [laughter]
it's funny, he does like a lot of very
sophisticated stuff um either on CUDA or
on the um on like uh Sim, not even SIMD,
what on um
yeah, SIMD and intrinsics as well. But
then like he'll miss things like, "Hey,
you can cash the [ __ ] map generation
and not have to optimize it because it
gets cold once."
Gemini 37. It's fast.
Is it actually decent though?
I don't know. Every time I've tried to
mess with Gemini, their thing has just
been a nightmare.
I know it's really annoying that it's
the most like the most frequent question
I get asked is about this stupid
language model rather than like any of
the actually cool RL stuff. Like do you
not see that these are like 40
environments here that are being rldled
in most of them in like 2 minutes from
scratch
here. This is breakout 882 milliseconds
for a solve. How's that look to you?
but nope. Groth. More interesting.
thing.
Oh, of course I don't have it live. This
is the local version.
Uh, where's Breakout? Here. All right.
So, this is our agent playing Breakout
in your browser.
You can train this in under a second.
We obviously have much more
sophisticated stuff than this.
We've got the fastest open source
self-driving sim. This is used
professionally.
Got a whole bunch of games.
This thing can smoke at Tetris.
And while this is generally boring and
annoying pre-release work,
um the cool thing with 50,
it's really simple. Like
the whole thing for 5, all of the train
visualization, everything code, it's
under 10k lines. So everything except
the environments is under 10k lines.
It's all uh end to end cud
like eight files total
super easy to work with like 5k lines
for the actual training uh and model
infrastructure and the rest is like
visualization and logging and and
sweeps.
Oh yes, this is still going.
The Tetris model is super fun to watch.
Tetris, it turns out, is actually kind
of too easy to solve to even be a a
useful research task for us.
It's like decent, but
it turned out to be kind of easy.
Obviously, Breakout is easier, but
Breakout we kind of just use as a quick
test. You can train it so fast.
It used to be that Pong would be the
quick test, but now this trains in like
100 milliseconds and it's too easy.
What are your local PC specs?
This machine here only has a 3080 on it.
Um, I have sshed into I have a uh a
machine that I own and I host that has a
5090. I actually have my own cluster but
several of the machines are down now and
I'm away so I can't really maintain them
uh until I'm back. Um,
and then at the moment because those
machines are down, I have an 8GPU vast
instance that I'm just sshed into with
85090s.
And those are currently being used
very inefficiently, only two of them.
Uh, but I'm using these basically to
triage various environments and testing.
this work on Wordle? So this does not
have language reasoning built in. The
way to think of this, this is like
tabular rasa RL meaning it is the model
starts as a blank slate. It learns
purely through interaction.
So basically anything that requires you
to read is going to be like one of the
worst possible things for it. It's
actually way easier to give it something
that requires vision even though it
doesn't have any vision to start with.
That's easier than giving it something
that requires full use of language.
Look up puffer four to five. So five is
end to end cud no Python at all. Um,
we're simplifying the algorithm a little
bit and still getting soda.
We have an async training mode that can
give you up to 2x PF and we've also
improved a lot of the kernels and that
gives you more perf as well. Um, we also
support GPU environments. And like the
this super fast speedrun showcase is
that we took breakout down from about 4
seconds to under 1 second in this
release.
over 60 million step per second training
on uh on Breakout.
Obviously, you get perf increases
everywhere,
but we like to have a speedrun task just
to show off. We kind of need a new
speedrun stuff like a visual stream.
Yeah, you can give it visuals. We tend
to give it state data. Um, so stuff
that's not even at all like
interpretable by humans whatsoever, but
is just really compact data on the
problem.
One way to commonly think of this is if
you think of playing a game, right? Like
um
like the game is not actually
maintaining the pixel representation
that you see internally. It just has
some state. Well, instead of having to
spend all the compute rendering pixels
and processing pixels, we just give the
agent state data that would be used to
render it. Anyways,
it's kind of equivalent in a sense and
just much faster.
I don't think we've ever really seen
pixels be like hard or anything, just
slow.
Where did I lose my um Oh, there it is.
5.0 status.
random events which happen through
experiment or playthrough.
Yeah. So, we train really fast. Like, we
literally have setups where the thing
can play a month worth of games every
second of training.
It just it's incredibly high perf sim is
our solution to most problems.
Yeah, actually so if you want to chat
with Jess on that, uh we do have a
project now where we are trying to solve
or at least play chess reasonably well
with only selfplay, no human data and no
search. As you can imagine, that's
pretty tough. It's better than I am at
chess at the very least already. And um
I think that overall
it's not a chess problem that we're
having.
Uh it's more so we're having a
like an overall exploration problem with
our selfplay setup
and I think we're going to be able to
improve that pretty soon.
stayed away from chest premputee.
Uh it's not on the website yet, but it
will be.
I mean, Jess in the If you just join the
Discord, discord.gg/puffer,
uh Jess in there is the person to talk
to about chess.
He's quite good at chess as well. I'm
horrible at it. Hell.
Is this where the code exists
up? Yes, that's the main project.
Um, well, the main thing for that is
when I'm doing algo work, I have
environments that can train in under a
second that are like a decent indicator
that I haven't broken anything,
that are like not totally trivial. And
then I have pretty damn good
environments that are trainable in 3
minutes. And then I have really good
environments that I can train in 20
minutes to an hour.
And then our best environments that we
typically only run once or twice per
release and those will run over the
course of a few days.
What's your philosophy of money?
I mean, money is good, but I can't
actually buy all the stuff I want with
it. So,
money like buys me GPUs at least.
Like Puffer is not a nonprofit, you
know, we're open source, but we uh we do
contracts for companies. We have the
fastest open- source RL tools out there,
and there's really nothing better closed
source either. So, if you have RL and
you'd like it to be fast and like it to
work,
we are available.
Okay, this is good.
Pre-training.
We don't need pre-training in RMS. All
our stuff's tabularasa.
I mean, our models are absolutely tiny.
We just have super super fast ends.
Any form of pre-training that you would
want would be like give it a couple
demonstrations I guess.
Like we can make use of a little bit of
human data, but we wouldn't use it for
pre-training cuz like pre-training is
something that you do when like a lot of
your data is in the start phase and then
you do a little bit of training
afterwards. We do a lot of training
afterwards.
So if anything, it would be like an
auxiliary loss or whatever.
Um, it depends.
I would say that it is a very heavily
involved process at the very least.
Like
for environment code,
you're going to see me write a lot of
code just by hand straight up. Um, when
I'm writing,
when I'm doing research, some stuff is
manual and then some stuff is like, ah,
whatever, let it just try this idea out
and if it works, I'll implement it
cleanly.
Um, but a lot of the process of
implementing cleanly is kind of an
incremental fac incremental refactoring
process where I will use the models for
each clearly described step of that
But then I like I have to go through
many many iterations and then even
change you know a bunch of stuff
manually as well.
There's basically no amount of prompting
that's just going to get it to give you
good code though within a cycle or two.
It just has like too much ingrained big
tech junk.
the LLM like
no LLMs. It does like it seems like
compression objectives in general just
scale like nuts with parameters. So
whenever you have a compression
objective, which is what pre-training
is, you end up just scaling really hard
on the model size dimension.
RL doesn't seem to work that way. Like
the objective is way sparer. So you just
you need a ton of data to train
anything. And that also means that you
end up with much smaller models.
It's also funny though because you end
up getting task spec like single task or
like task specific
um superhuman models and they'll be 100k
parameters,
you know,
What?
Here. I'm wondering why my drink is uh
rolling and the bottom is like blown
out. That's bizarre.
Um,
what do I do about that?
Hang on. I'll be right back.
do you find ralli more useful for
corporate business environments
fine-tuning as opposed to
we don't do language stuff in general
man
like there are a lot of problems that
are optimization
over interactions on a fiddly sim where
no human intuition helps you at all. We
do this in finance, commerce, we've done
it in animation, we've done it in games,
we've done it in defense, lot of
different areas,
I've been summoned. Yeah, Jess, you um
someone was asking about chess.
See what we have in here.
Okay, this is better.
Basically, everything else everything is
in here now.
Net hack
smoke tested on net hack.
We just make the performance on net hack
the rate of ascension and it's just zero
forever [clears throat]
for anybody not familiar with Net Hack,
go play that game.
I'll take the like AGI claim seriously
when the models are beating net hack
to be fair if they find
but they do it if they fine-tuned on
Zero shot. No way. No way they do it.
Zero shot. Even with access to the wiki.
What would you recommend to get started
on RL? Hello. Welcome. Um, my guides. I
got guides on X.
You go to my articles tab. This is all
of our research, but also,
They link you to entirely free resources
and they give you a lot of good advice.
It's pretty much all my best advice in
one place.
Generally, the best way to learn is to
just start doing some of this stuff,
though. Like, you know, go sling a
puffer environment together.
Look how many environments we have from
contributors.
All these,
all these are different ends. And look,
I'm actually going through and I'm
trying to get them all to work.
What's going on? We are currently
attempting
uh we are attempting to get all of the
enms wrangled for our next release.
Does anybody have any particular
investment in any of these?
The only one I see that I really am sad
that never got finished as this tactics
ends
because this is basically a dope sim.
which if you're not familiar with that
game, it's kind of like old Fire Emblem
combat.
That'd make a cool end.
Action Space is kind of a nightmare, but
it's cool.
New project for you. You have enough
stuff, Jess.
What we got? Battle trains.
Okay,
nice.
Works.
Uh,
it's still figuring out Dr. Mario.
I'd like to actually be able to test
some of these.
We definitely need to figure out our
gold set of Ms.
What else do we need on 5? It's a whole
bunch of usability stuff, right?
I still have to finish the puffer fish
thing, don't I?
That's a tomorrow type thing, though.
I think we can probably do like a gold
set of M or whatever.
represent like our coolest and highest
quality ends
and then constellation will have gold
and over.
I mean, why would you read the papers if
you don't care about them?
Oh, you know what we can do? We can
start pulling in some other ends.
Let me go check for some stuff that got
um
let me go check some of the M's that
just got like crunched in the 50 PR are.
We can just go we can get those
understand ML stuff better might
translate. Well, why don't you read
stuff in the area that you care about
instead?
Like you're telling me you've read all
the papers.
Hey, Joseph. What's RL?
Uh,
radioactive lightning.
Now, reinforcement learning.
We train agents to solve tasks.
by interacting with Sims
for a very long time. Except it doesn't
take a very long time because our Sims
are really fast.
That's your late Friday night level
explanation.
Oh, well, now I'm in darkness.
Okay, I'll keep the light on for the
stream.
Did I not do that?
We on Polar Express.
is open source. Are using agents can use
agent? What?
Yes, it's open source. We train agents
here to play games.
I'm not really using the agent to train
the agents at the moment here as much as
I am just using it to orchestrate a
bunch of experiments and do really
really basic like basic admin work and
job launching.
It's massively overkill, but it saves me
quite a bit of manual annoying [ __ ]
work. So
that's what's going on at the moment.
The slightly more um the slightly less
trivial thing that I am also having it
do at the moment is just like triage
obvious fixes like pattern match the
common bugs that we have from other
ends.
Mostly just small port issues though.
Nothing really too critical.
Tron game. Oh, is that is that actually
PR?
If that's PR, I'll grab it.
I'll just see what other things is
targeting.
trajectory. I don't know what you mean
by that.
this weekend. It will be I'll get it in
this weekend so I can merge it to uh get
it into the 5 release just in time. It's
going to be another couple weeks for 5,
but I'm going to probably stop merging
new ends pretty soon.
I'm doing the big batch of them now
pretty much.
Okay. Yes, that is what a trajectory is.
But you asked me like what is the
capital T trajectory?
So
you did not ask me for like a definition
of basic RL term. I didn't think
So, and Pathfinder
Pathfinder
all of Kinvert's stuff
it's out got merged.
Is dog fight? Whatever happened to dog
side.
faster than I was writing. Yeah, but the
port is basic, dude.
Like the update is really easy.
Actually,
it's been that way for the last couple
versions. Like, nothing has actually
required you to overhaul in any
meaningful way. Just a couple API
changes.
Custom selfplay.
So, we no longer care if you have custom
stuff, but it is on you to figure out
what it is like to fix it.
The thing I will do on your behalf now
is if you are just going to run a
language model to like update it, I'll
do that for you. I don't particularly
care. But if you want an actually good
fix to anything, then yeah, you have to
do it.
Hello.
Uh,
so what we're going to basically Oh god,
Flappy.
We'll triage. We're probably going to
delete any of these that like really
suck. But I figure what we'll do is
since it's basically free to pull them
in, we'll basically take all the ends,
we'll pull them all in, we'll update
them, we'll see whether they're fast and
useful, and then what I'm going to start
doing since we're getting so many damn
endpring
them. Like the ends that we actually use
and trust that have stood the test of
time are going to be graded gold.
The ends that are like nice but need
some work or need some more time in the
tank
are going to be silver.
And everything else is just going to get
the default puffer cyan.
will use agent ops. What? What is that
crap?
Very very little of my work looks like
what you're seeing now, right? I'm
basically doing what you're seeing now
because this is a chunk of my work
that I have to do every release. That's
always a pain. It's just like a lot of
janitorial work, right?
And instead of taking a week to do this,
I figure we can do it this weekend
with this thing and be done. And for all
the gold M's, I'm going to make sure
that nothing's gotten messed up. And for
all the silver M, I'm at least going to
go look at them and see how close they
are to being ready to be gold.
And that's fine as long as it's not
messing constellation.
Constellation does not have the similar
patterns.
Very different.
dynamic systems take.
So basically that's a nothing word.
Yeah, that's to tell that's a nothing
word.
I like the idea of having the the color
grading for the Ms.
It just makes my life a lot easier
thinking about stuff
cuz now instead of like, oh no, I have
all these M to fix. It's just like, no,
I just have to think about what M's I
want to be in this like the nice fixed
set.
Grock 4.6. Yikes. So, you like sitting
in front of your computer waiting
forever to do nothing because the model
takes forever to run anything.
It's fast.
I don't need it to be smart because I am
smart. Thank you very much.
Or at least I'm not completely glueingly
[ __ ] most of the time. I don't know
if I'll go as far as to say smart,
but um the bar has been very low for
that particular attribute lately.
If you are expecting some polish here,
note that this is now our we're going
into eighth hour streaming today.
okay,
silver. Okay, that looks nice, right?
Gold, silver.
Nice. I like this. Yeah, I like this
idea.
I found it to generally be a pain.
At least previously, it was tied to all
Google's like super heavy crap.
llama
hundreds to thousands. So like there is
a lower bound, right?
I don't need the models to be smart, but
they need to at least be coherent.
I basically didn't use the models at all
um before the start of this year because
for my taste they were like just
incoherent. Like they did not even save
time
at all for anything.
I'm trying to think what we want to do
here.
>> [sighs]
>> What is left to do on the release? So, I
have some code review to do.
We need the sweeps obviously for all the
important ends for constellation.
We want a couple soda results on the
bigger ends.
I think it's just the end side work
maybe after that.
go back.
So, right now it's not writing a massive
amount of code.
Like this here is pulling in existing
code and it's essentially just making
very minor API upgrades.
So despite today being like all agent
crap except for this morning where I was
doing more refactoring stuff,
um it's not really writing much code.
This is mostly like
this is mostly like maintenance and
integration I'm doing at the moment.
Pre-release work is what it is. Like it
says right right up there, right? It's
pre-release work.
Just got to pull in all the new ends.
See what looks cool and then what's
going to be in the in what list.
Note that we're way more protective
about the quality of our core code than
we are about environments because like
if somebody wants to submit an
environment that's not good, it's fine.
Like people just won't use it.
you don't actually even include that
like you don't include every environment
in the compilation anyways like when you
build puffer you build it against one
environment but like their code the code
literally doesn't even factor into
anything if uh if we have like a couple
bad ends
you should Joseph check all the ends I
am going to do that for the ones that I
know are like LLM crap
But I don't know if I'm going to spend
the effort, Jess. I will probably do
that if it's like this is a cool end if
it were written well, you know?
manually review the cool ones. Yeah,
I could
What time is it? 8:37. I'll work another
20 minutes.
Because those are terminals that are on
Linux tabs. I don't know what to tell
you.
Those aren't browser.
thought it was a browser.
It's all right.
I'm answering questions kind of grumpily
at this point because I stream a lot
today.
And that's the model being stupid trying
to like add website paths to the
training config.
their extra tool costs.
Well, I don't know what they do in uh in
tokens, but I'm just using the default
plan and I haven't run out yet.
So, so far, no.
right? Yes, I do write lots of code. I
would like to be writing more code
every time I have to boot up a stream
for something that's not core dev.
Do people seriously have nothing better
to ask me than like
the bloody like language model? It's the
least important thing possible on the
entire stream.
I guess that's kind of my fault for just
standing here like looking at [ __ ]
here.
what's going on here. Okay,
so this is kind of just like a chill
maintenance. Like it takes a long time
to do this work whether I do it manually
or semi-automatically.
Um,
look, we have all of these environments.
As you see, they're actually like
another five or 10 getting merged in.
Um, like 60 environments.
All of them need to run training
correctly. They all ideally need to at
least produce something reasonable when
you train on them. Uh, ideally they are
up to our performance specs.
Um, ideally like we rate the good ones
and make sure that the ones that like we
typically rely on are all beating
previous state-of-the-art because of the
new update.
And typically this just means like three
weeks of very very boring work where I
have to very slowly like run this end,
run that end, fix this tiny integration
bug, fix that tiny integration bug.
We're automating most of this crap that
time or most of that crap this time
rather. It's really easy work. I already
s kind of took care of most of the like
ah I know why that specific env is jank
here. Let's fix that earlier today.
They're going to be a couple things that
I still have to do on some of the the
more complex ends.
Technical details of my workflow. Well,
really it depends what I'm working on,
right?
My favorite stuff is when I'm working on
a sim and then I kind of just get to jam
some classic C. That's really nice. Um,
for algo work, depending on what it is,
if it's like a like out there idea where
I'm like, ah, I wonder if this works. I
don't really care if I get a false um a
false negative, then I'll just have LLM
go try it. And if the result works then
I will actually bother to look at it and
implement it correctly myself.
Um if it is like a core algorithm thing
that has to work in the sense that like
it is a crucial thing that exists for
puffer. We know it will work. It just
has to be done correctly. Then the
process gets to be much more manual.
Um,
I actually, one of the things that
bothered me a lot was the lack of
ability to do work manually when needed
because of just all of the LLM shitty
code bloat
as well as not just LLM bloat, but just
the um transitioning pain from
to pure CUD to Cy, which is why I spent
a good two to three weeks this uh this
update just cutting down the code size.
Um, so now we have less than 10k total
lines. We have less than 5k lines for
the actual core. We actually have like a
really compact thing that it's pretty
easy to iterate on now.
And that's going to set us up very
nicely for future algo dev as well.
Nope.
Low hanging fruit for RL and Puffer in
general. That's a nice question.
So,
I mean, we're pretty damn good on Perf
at this point. Like, we have really good
Perf. Um, anything architecture- wise
that we do at this point would be pretty
tough.
We've gone into selfplay and we think
that we're basically bottlenecked by
exploration, which is not easy at all.
The curriculum stuff that we want to do
in Puffer 6, I still think will work,
but it's not going to be easy either.
Not at all.
I think probably the next thing like
that would be kind of obvious is that
Puffer is just really good now and we
could probably solve a lot of really
impressive tasks just by throwing
existing Puffer defaults plus sweep at
it.
So, I think if anything, the lowhanging
fruit would just be like ludicrously
cool demos.
You can't quite vibe code all of that
yet. Um, but it's kind of near the point
where Puffer Core is just so good that
like you can almost vibe code very cool
looking things. Um, you probably can
fake like a fair bit of it to be fair,
but like the actual demos that RL people
will look at and say, "Damn, that's
impressive." Those you still can't vibe
code. Those you still need to know what
you're doing. Um,
but that's mostly a testament to like
just how stable Puffer is is what I
meant that as, right?
Like Puffer is very, very stable at this
point.
There are a couple places where there's
a little bit of jank. Okay. Another
thing that we could do that's like
lowhanging fruit would just be like
going through existing places where
stuff is jank and trying to understand
why like with hyperparameters and stuff.
That's probably pretty lowhanging fruit.
I mean, we're just mostly trying to
figure out stuff like why we
occasionally still get really low clip
coefficients and lambda terms appearing
in uh in sweeps.
improve on puffer is kind of like that.
It will just fail.
Why are they bad?
Uh, clip coefficients mean that like
you're doing something kind of weird to
the optimizer
because
you're stopping most of the gradients,
It's kind of just like a nonsensical
setting that sometimes works for a
reason we don't understand why. There
are a few things like this that still
happen sometimes.
They also tend not to replicate very
well like across seeds. They tend to be
pretty unstable hypers.
I fully believe that language models
will give us like fairly impressive
narrow intelligence.
Oh, I've just left it off by default.
Whatever though, they'll just scrape
like final puffer li anyways. is
I don't know maybe if they make the
thing free and then they swerve serve my
queries twice is fast.
Oops.
That's playing pong.
Cool.
Little janky. We should probably
constrain the frame skip to not be able
to be that um that Hi.
Just render it smoothly. We could do
that as well.
That's probably significantly better.
It's not disingenuous.
Ram skip is literally just it holding
the key down.
just so like I can figure out what ends
are working.
That's going to break.
May his works.
This is throwaway. So, yes,
the rest of it is not really webdev.
It's just uploading websites to the
folder. I mean uploading um
uploading m to the folder. There.
Well, honestly, it's not like the web
stuff really isn't that bad given that
it's just it's HTM HTML, a little bit of
CSS, and a tiny bit of JavaScript. All
the interactive stuff for the most part.
It's just the um web assembly build of
the ends.
Yeah. So, we'll fix this stuff tomorrow.
Frame rate issues.
tried multiGPU. I think multiGPU works
now. I'm pretty sure.
I think we fixed that. I'm not positive.
That was a bad bug, though.
patch the versions from a few hours ago.
Really?
I merged to 50 like pretty few hours
ago. I guess I merged this
so that we actually have a full
pre-release branch.
Oh,
here's Kin Vertion lock.
Here's Clifford En.
Apparently, this is quantum something or
other.
Nice.
Gorilla checkers
ants. This is a super old end, but it's
kind of cool.
Well, this is locally, but yeah. Yeah,
I'm just pour I was just pulling in all
the M's. Convert
reaction.
That's a little bit of a mess.
pulling it in five minutes though,
guaranteed.
But I think what we're going to do,
uh, take a quick look at some of these
ends and we're going to launch a sweep
the night.
I like this one. this like boss fight.
En
the key and
missing uh some assets it seems.
[gasps]
It actually merged one of the flappy
events. That's so funny.
I don't know if this is actually like
the best one.
Reading floaty puffer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
All right, I'll have to figure that out.
Jess, my bad.
I know multiGPU sweeps I think works.
Maybe not.
fun for selfplay. Yay, that uh they
dropped by the stream earlier saying
that they would do that.
Hello.
Oh, that's fine.
I don't know why the [ __ ] it does this.
They're just very dumb
sometimes.
Okay, I'll double check on this before I
go to sleep. I'm going to just take like
um probably just make sure this is going
for the next 40 minutes,
chill a little bit, and then uh in the
morning tomorrow,
I'm going to get up. I'm going to go for
a run and we're going to get as much as
possible
uh of the 50 pre-release end stuff done
so that Sunday and Monday we can really
just be working on like core docs
um any broken [ __ ]
Thank you for that.
Let me click one thing.
Yeah, that's a bunch of nice runs. Look
at that.
All right, thank you everyone.
discord.gg/puffer GG/puffer
for uh dev
puffer.ai for all the stuff. Star the
puffer. I'm exhausted. I'm going to call
it a night.